let me bring up the next topic that
people don't want to mention
although they're getting more
comfortable with it is consciousness you
mentioned that you have a talk on
consciousness
that i watched five minutes of but the
internet connection was really bad
was this my talk about you know uh uh
refuting the integrated information
theory
yes which is a particular account of
consciousness that yeah i think
one can just show it doesn't work so let
me much harder to say what does work
what doesn't work yeah yeah let me ask
maybe it'd be nice to uh comment on
you talk about also like the semi-hard
problem conscious or like almost hard
pro or kind of hard pretty pretty hard
pretty hard one
so maybe can you uh talk about that uh
their
idea of um of uh the approach to
modeling consciousness and why you don't
find it convincing
what is it first of all okay well so so
what what what i
called the pretty hard problem of
consciousness this is my term although
many other people have said something
equivalent to this okay uh but uh
it's just you know the the problem
of you know giving an account of just
which physical systems
are conscious and which are not or you
know if there are degrees of
consciousness then quantifying how
conscious
a given system is oh awesome so that's
the pretty hard yeah
that's what i mean that's it i'm
adopting it i love it that's a good
a good ring to it and so you know the
infamous hard problem of consciousness
is to explain how something like
consciousness could arise at all
you know in a material universe right or
you know why does it ever feel like
anything
to to uh experience anything right and
you know so i'm trying to distinguish
from that problem
right and say you know no okay i am i
would merely settle for an account
that could say you know is a fetus
conscious
you know if so at which trimester you
know is a uh
is a dog conscious you know what about a
frog
right or or even as a precondition you
take that both these things are
conscious
tell me which is more conscious yeah for
example yes
yeah yeah i mean if consciousness is
some multi-dimensional vector well just
tell me in which respects these things
are conscious and in which respect they
aren't
right and you know and have some
principled way to do it where you're not
you know carving out exceptions for
things that you like or don't like
but could somehow take a description of
an arbitrary physical system
and then just based on the physical
properties of that system
or the informational properties or how
it's connected or something like that
just in principle calculate you know its
degree of consciousness
right i mean this this this would be the
kind of thing that we would need
you know if we wanted to address
questions like you know
what does it take for a machine to be
conscious right or when or
you know when when when should we regard
ais as being conscious
um so now this iit
this integrated information theory uh
which has been put forward by
uh giulio tanoni and a bunch of his uh
uh collaborators over the last
decade or two uh this is noteworthy i
guess
as a direct attempt to answer that
question
to you know answer the to address the
pretty hard problem
right and they give a uh a criterion
that's just based on how a system is
connected so you so it's up to you
to sort of abstract the system like a
brain or a microchip
as a collection of components that are
connected to each other by some
pattern of connections you know and and
to specify
how the components can influence each
other you know like where the inputs go
you know where they affect the outputs
but then once you've specified that
then they give this quantity that they
call fee you know the greek letter
phi and the definition of phi is
actually changed over time
it changes from one paper to another but
in all of the
variations it involves something about
what we in computer science would call
graph expansion so basically what this
means is that they want
it uh um in order to get a large value
of fee
uh it should not be possible to take
your system and partition it
into two components that are only weakly
connected to each other okay so whenever
we take our system and
sort of try to split it up into two then
there should be lots and lots of
connections going between the two
components
okay well i understand what that means
on a graph do they formalize
what uh how to construct such a graph or
data structure whatever
uh or is this well one of the criticism
uh
i i've heard you kind of say is that a
lot of the very interesting specifics
are usually communicated through
like natural language like like through
words
so it's like the details aren't always
well they well it's true i mean they
they they they have nothing even
resembling a derivation
of this fee okay so what they do is they
state a whole bunch of postulates
you know axioms that they think that
consciousness should satisfy
and then there's some verbal discussion
and then at some point
fee appears right right and this this
was one the first thing that really made
the hair stand on my neck to be honest
because
they are acting as if there is a
derivation they're acting as if you know
you're supposed to think that this is a
derivation and there's nothing even
remotely resembling
a derby they just pull the fee out of a
hat completely is one of the key
criticisms to you is that details are
missing or is that exactly more fun
that's not even the key criticism that's
just that's just a side point
okay the the core of it is that i think
that the you know that they want to say
that a system is more conscious
the larger its value of fee and i think
that that is obvious nonsense
okay as soon as you think about it for
like a minute as soon as you think about
it in terms of
could i construct a system that had an
enormous value of
fee like you know even larger than the
brain has
but that is just implementing an error
correcting code you know doing nothing
that we would
associate with you know intelligence or
consciousness or any of it
the answer is yes it is easy to do that
right
and so i wrote blog posts just making
this point that yeah it's easy to do
that
now you know tanoni's response to that
was actually kind of incredible
right i mean i i admired it in a way
because instead of disputing any of it
he just bit the bullet in the sense you
know he was one of the the uh
the most uh audacious bullet bitings
i've ever seen in my career
okay he said okay then fine
you know this system that just applies
this error correcting code it's
conscious
you know and if it has a much larger
value of fee then
you or me it's much more conscious than
you want me interesting you know you we
just have to accept what the theory says
because you know science is not about
confirming our intuitions it's about
challenging them
and you know this is what my theory
predicts that this thing is conscious
and you know or super duper conscious
and how are you going to prove me wrong
so the way i would argue against your
blog post
is i would say yes sure you're right in
general but
for naturally arising systems developed
through the process of evolution on
earth
the this rule of the larger fee being
associated being associated with more
consciousness is correct
yeah so that's not what he said at all
right right because he wants this to be
completely general
right so we can apply to even computers
yeah i mean i mean the whole interest of
the theory is the
you know the hope that it could be
completely general apply to aliens to
computers to
uh uh uh animals coma patients to any of
it
right yeah and uh uh so so so
he just said well you know uh scott is
relying on his intuition but you know
i'm relying on this theory
and you know to me it was almost like
you know are we being serious here
like like like you know like like okay
yes in science we try to learn highly
non-intuitive things but what we do is
we
first test the theory on cases where we
already know the answer
right like if if someone had a new
theory of temperature
right then you know maybe we could check
that it says that
boiling water is hotter than ice and
then if it says that the sun is hotter
than anything you know you've ever
experienced then maybe we we trust that
extrapolation
right but like this this theory like if
if
you know it's now saying that you know
a a gigantic grit like regular grid of
exclusive or gates
can be way more conscious than a you
know a person or than any animal can be
you know even if it you know is you know
is is
is is so uniform that it might as just
well just be a blank wall
right and and so now the point is if
this theory is sort of getting wrong
the question is a blank wall you know
more conscious than a person
then i would say what is what is there
for it to get right
so your sense is a blank wall uh
is not more conscious than a human being
yeah i mean i mean i mean
you could say that i am taking that as
one of my axioms
i'm saying i'm saying that if if a
theory of consciousness
is is get getting that wrong then
whatever it is talking about
at that point i i uh i'm not going to
call it consciousness
i'm going to use a different word you
have to use a different word i mean it's
all it's possible
just like with intelligence that us
humans conveniently define these very
difficult to understand concepts
in a very human-centric way just like
the touring test
really seems to define intelligence as a
thing that's human-like
right but i would say that with any uh
concept
you know there's uh uh
you know like we we we first need to
define it right and a definition is only
a good definition
if it matches what we thought we were
talking about you know prior to having a
definition
right yeah and i would say that you know
uh fee
as a definition of consciousness fails
that test
that is my argument so okay let's so
let's
take a further step so you mentioned
that the universe might be
uh the touring machine so like it might
be computational or simulatable by one
anyway
simulated by one so yeah do what's your
sense
about consciousness do you think
consciousness is computation
that we don't need to go to any place
outside of the computable universe
to uh you know to to understand
consciousness to
build consciousness to measure
consciousness all those kinds of things
i don't know these are what uh you know
have been called the
the vertigonous questions right there's
the questions like
like uh you know you get a feeling of
vertigo and thinking about them
right i mean i certainly feel like uh
i am conscious in a way that is not
reducible to computation
but why should you believe me right i
mean and
and if you said the same to me then why
should i believe you
but as computer scientists yeah i feel
like
a computer could be intel could achieve
human level intelligence
but and that's actually a feeling and a
hope that's not a scientific
belief it's just we've built up enough
intuition the same kind of intuition you
use in your blog
it's you know that's what scientists do
they i mean some of it is a scientific
method but some of it is just damn good
intuition
i don't have a good intuition about
consciousness yeah i'm not sure that
anyone does or or has in the
you know 2 500 years that these things
have been discussed lex
but do you think we will like one of the
i've gotten a chance to
attend i can't wait to hear your opinion
on this but attend the neuralink event
and uh one of the dreams there is to uh
you know basically push neuroscience
forward and the hope with neuroscience
is that uh we can inspect the machinery
from which
all this fun stuff emerges and see we're
gonna notice something
special some special sauce from which
something like consciousness or
cognition emerges
yeah well it's clear that we've learned
an enormous amount about neuroscience
we've learned an enormous amount about
computation you know about machine
learning about
you'll know ai how to get it to work
we've learned uh
an enormous amount about the
underpinnings of the physical world
you know and you know it from one point
of view
that's like an enormous distance that
we've traveled along the road to
understanding consciousness
from another point of view you know the
distance still to be traveled
on the road you know maybe seems no
shorter than it was at the beginning
yeah right so it's very hard to say i
mean you know these are
questions like like in in in sort of
trying to have a theory of consciousness
there's sort of a problem where it feels
like
it's not just that we don't know how to
make progress it's that it's hard to
specify
what could even count as progress right
because no matter what scientific theory
someone proposed
someone else could come along and say
well you've just talked about the
mechanism you haven't said anything
about
what breathes fire into the mechanism
right really makes there's something
that it's like to be
it right and that seems like an
objection that you could always raise
yes no matter you know how much someone
elucidated the details of how the brain
works
you